free mosquitoes so edgy I'm on it okay
we got this for the itching this for the
swelling and xanax just for fun well
that's the thing I'm anniversary is next
week and I still don't know together I
emailed you my nurses wishlist there are
five things on there but you only need
to get me three oh I got some things
delay yeah uh just a little bit corn
chips cookies whole rotisserie chicken
what's wrong it's not good it's not what
I ordered but it's fine I got a burger
but it's a study back I'm not even that
hungry listen are you joking no excuse
me
yeah hi this is actually not what he
ordered oh yeah let me exchange that
thank you so much and would you mind
just cuz I'm already almost done maybe
we can take that off the bill and also
maybe get like a beer on the house yeah
of course
Estela yeah sure great thank you
how did you do that that was incredible
you're allowed to send stuff back this
one is roasted turkey but there's
another one so you can decide this one
is black bean and sweet potato turns out
he's the one that buck allergic to dairy
oh wow you didn't tell me your boss was
Jewish
we go to the same synagogue and his
mom's cousin is my best friend's
sister's gynecologist her cousin Glendon
my nephew's fiance's colonoscopy Oh
crazy she's fabulous you're coming to
dinner you like cigars
sure so you just joined the company five
years ago really mango guacamole very
fancy boy bingo two bananas
perfect crackers how is everything
the pastas a little cold actually let me
heat that up for you thank you
what so pushy we're paying for a nice
meal I don't think is recalled it's not
too much faster than as an away from the
messenger you did Oh sushi
and two cheesecakes Wow drink anything
else I should have gone more I knew it
was good
babe this is feeding an army right here
you're just being nice